[Music]
uh
so did you hear okay so there's a
voice-over guy who does uh the voice
work for call of duty
well i'm sure there's probably a couple
be amazing if there's just one guy
a gentleman who does a voice for call of
duty
he's so annoyed at me already call of
duty cuts ties with ghost
ghost uh ghost voice actor over sexist
comments which one kevin spacey
cult no he's still allowed call of duty
makes activision have
uh call of duty makers activision have
cut ties with jeff leach the voice actor
behind ghost
over recently surfaced comments that are
equal parts sexist and shocking
isn't jeff leach the comedian yeah isn't
he the guy that wears all the bracelets
and the
he's like like tries to be like the
british johnny depp he's always on
compounds
according to statements released back
division sexism has no place in the
industry
and thus it decided to no longer be
working with leech
leech hasn't always been the voice of
ghost uh modern warfare
the character was played by craig
fairbass at the moment there's been no
word who will take over the character
uh now that leech has been given the
boot what activision does note
is that it strongly condemns the remarks
made by leach that's
committed to delivering a fun and safe
experience
the activision says sexism has no place
in our industry or games in our society
activision no longer working with jeff
leach we strongly condemn his remarks we
are committed to delivering fun and safe
experience
the decision was made after a video
surfaced on twitter and began to make
the rounds
compiling a handful of recess recent and
sexist comments made by leech during a
stream elsewhere so would you like to
see
the reason that this guy can't be a
voice actor because i have the video
here yeah this is the guy this is the
guy that was on uh
the jeff leach he's been on compound
he's been on all these podcasts
so this is what he did no wonder why
zombie unicorn didn't want to come on
she didn't want to come on yeah
she'd have to actually be amusing yeah
she could just rely on them here we go
horrendous cleavage i said it on twitch
or horrendous cleavage
jeff be a nice guy right now you came
here because you're a [ __ ] simple
with a saggy vagine that's why you came
over here
by the way you can go back and tell that
[ __ ] boy that he wouldn't say any of
that [ __ ] to my face
because i'm a giant i'd crack him in arm
which is what i would do to you if you
weren't so
[ __ ] ugly do me a favor darling
see yourself out and don't let the door
hit your fat ass on the way out i love
how it's always like some
dirty dirty gross
[ __ ] looking emo she looks like she
[ __ ] has no chance of getting a bit
of dick in her
see you later leah suck my fat girthy
cocky stupid
i don't give a [ __ ] you're gone you're
done you're banned you're out of here
fashion gaming streams uh yeah
typical gaming stream right and because
of that he's not allowed
but it gets even better so he's not
allowed to do it check this out coming
into my community
misogynistic place your females cameras
regularly so after that video now check
this out this is a female gaming stream
okay
this is [ __ ] cancer all right before
we
hit play on this sure be careful you're
not going to the new voiceover
for call of duty if you say anything bad
why are they pretending like
jeff leach who's going around abusing
young girls
in chat rooms when they're coming into
his chat right yes
right like if it's it's almost like okay
i would understand i would actually be
okay with uh you getting kicked off a
platform
if you were going around and doing like
raids
like chat room raids on other shows but
the shows were like
15 year old girls and you're in there
being like you [ __ ]
like i could understand the platform
being like we're kicking you off of here
you're fighting with literal female
children on their own streams like stop
it
but he's doing his [ __ ] people are
coming in and going who's this
who's this [ __ ] loser and then he's
reacting to it
and then they're going please i'm a
woman it's misogyny i'm a victim
women wanna women wanna be a part of the
gaming community they wanna be just like
men right like oh yeah yeah we're cool
man we could take it we're like dudes
but you're not see this is what happens
you wanna be led into these things that
are normally male dominated worlds like
gaming
and then when you are you ruin them it's
like when you're at a bar with a bunch
of friends and then their [ __ ] weird
girlfriend shows up
and then you can't joke about anything
or make jokes about anything anymore
because she showed up it's like no we
were fine
until you came mike you're social
vampires it's like letting a vampire in
to a house you invite a vampire and
vampires come in and they murder
everybody in that house
you somehow escape you make it safely
into a new house
and now the vampires are knocking on the
door and they're going
invite us in and the new people are
going do not invite them in and you're
going
put this nicely every time you invite
them in they kill everybody
marsh you remember back when we were
younger
the halo 3 lobbies and the horrendous
things that were said
in those lobbies i mean you want to talk
about n-bombs you want to talk about
f-slurs you want to talk about
everything
sometimes before the match even began
like i'm talking like people
people yelling at each other who have no
reason to even be beefing yet
bloodthirsty lunatics
uh you know baseblader says uh okay the
misogyny thing is silly in general but
come on guys
when you speak like that an
entertainment company is going to
distance themselves no no you're right
you're right like other people in
entertainment companies that said why
all white people are the devil and they
get more jobs
the same people that work for
entertainment companies and says you're
born with
white privilege the same thing that says
that all white babies are racist and
then they win an oscar and win a [ __ ]
emmy and a [ __ ] golden globe
so now the same companies that condone
the same companies that give me a
[ __ ] hate speech strike and by the
way my my appeal was denied
uh and i get kicked off twitch and i get
suspended for a week on youtube and i'm
gonna miss my birthday show
uh all that but you can go on there and
say i want we should
kill all white men we should kill them
and then they get promoted so yeah let's
stop pretending
like this there's an even distribution
or like these companies are apolitical
by the way call of duty is a game where
you go and you literally blow people's
brains off for being brown skinned
so that's not funny what a weird high
ground right but check this out
mike we have some competition in the
podcast let's see what these slobs have
to say
video uh serious and unforgivable sexism
it follows that jeff leach does not
respect women as equals
i don't so is this like a twitch version
of the view
no more people watch this can we call
this the ew
[Laughter]
so as girl gamers what do we do as a
collective
stop playing games if you cannot handle
the bans
why are you doing this and what's with
the one in the upper right-hand corner
she's got like caitlyn jenner eyes
i see that black eyes like a doll's eyes
no but look how cr like
look at how [ __ ] up one of them is
like it's not even placed properly
on the on the bot like if you made that
as a character in a game you'd be like i
have to start the whole face over i
don't know what happened to the eye
look at the buckle up buckaroo eyes one
is like
in and completely wow well the only way
to see is when she plays call of duty
just hits people with her car
to change the way certain males view
women we speak out i mean if you're
silent ultimately
yeah you're going to change the way
males males
look at women by being weak all you're
going to do is make more dudes hate you
and by the way you're also going to just
make like you you just
like what's gonna happen is you're gonna
do all this and then
what's gonna happen is the thought
streamers are still gonna make all the
money
you're gonna make no money and these
platforms that you're helping to
bankrupt or eventually someday
not even gonna be able to pay you
because
they they needed streamers like us to
make the money
they needed streamers like jeff leach
they needed streamers like nick fuentes
they
they need streamers like that the big
dick daddies of the show of the platform
to pull in the numbers
that justify paying you guys your little
[ __ ]
your 38 dollar twitch payouts every two
months
if the silence watch ultimately is part
of the problem right if you
see something or you're aware of
something and you choose to let it slide
because maybe it doesn't bother you
right i'm very hard to offend hey
she's very hard to offend bro she's
listen she's super hard to she likes to
joke around as good as an ex guy
you know what i mean she's got a real
sick sense of humor so she gets it
all her friends are dudes she can even
hang out with women dude are you kidding
me
bro she gets it she knows what the
limits are
right i'm very hard to offend so you
look very easy to offend
you honestly you're the one talking
right now and you somehow still look
offended yeah
like you look perpetually offended
to offend so let's say maybe that didn't
offend me
if i chose to not say something i'm then
part of the problem
so snitch on everybody even when you're
not offended is what you're saying
that is correct just you mention
everyone all the time you
beg to come into this community and then
they let you in this community
and then the first thing you do is start
ratting other people out for making
jokes
and then it's fine because we're just
going to move on to some other thing
but then you guys are going to want to
get in on that and ruin that
and someday man you're going to have to
start drawing a line here
um you got to draw a line in the sand
like i'm not saying obviously you can't
stop
women from streaming or playing video
games but
you can stop simping for them you can
stop
pulling this milady [ __ ] like all you
[ __ ] fat neckbeards do with these
vidcons
and these twitch cons and giving them
piggyback rides and carrying their bags
around and and
screaming at people on the internet to
call them out for this
uh which remember says it's fine because
jeff leech sucks look jeffy
might suck i don't even know the [ __ ]
guy but that's not my point
yeah i know he was on compound one time
and i'm sure mike david hates him but
that aside jim think outside your
[ __ ]
think outside the button for once in
your life it has nothing to do with
whether or not he sucks
we know can you do us a favor jim can
you just write down everybody that mike
david hates for us and we'll keep a list
here
so that you can save yourself the energy
of typing it out every time
then part of the problem you know and
and for him to take it as a comedic
joke about our female
a comedic joke first off all
jokes are comedic you stupid like how
our physique is
it just it's just appalling because
there are so many stereotypes as it is
with females
as it is what i'm actually looking
forward to and i'm not kidding you one
of the reasons i'm really looking
forward to going to the gym again
is it bothers them oh yeah it bothers
these these fats
and i really i want to go back to being
in decent shape
so i can just get suspended on twitter
for being like
shut up ah
yeah you can tell father's like you turn
it into a joke you turn
physique into a joke and it's like you
can just tell it really bothers them
but it's like who has more control over
your
jeff leech or you
being fat and for him to take it as a
comedic
joke about our female like how our
physique is
it just it's just appalling because
there are so many stereotypes as
yeah they're there there's a stereotype
with women a stereotype that you're very
easily offended
that you immediately wrap people out and
now you're reinforcing those stereotypes
that you're weak
this is weak behavior you're being weak
is with females as it is and then for us
to be the minority in
a gaming community you're the minority
in the gaming community because you
want to be you're the minority in the
gaming community
in the same way that sixes go to
comic-cons
because in a comic-con you're a 10
compared to because hot chicks aren't
gonna go there unless they're working
yeah not anymore though oh yeah well
that's true
that's why they're moving into you're
saying like comic-cons years ago
years ago yeah yeah when they were but
now like the bad boys are all going to
comic-con
and now you've been relegated to
twitchcon and
animecon and all those and furry con and
all these
weird [ __ ] ones types as it is with
females
as it is and then for us to be the
minority in the gaming community
what is with that joyless
always on the verge of crying tone in
their voice right
well she's a dude so wait for real
i can't i mean i don't know i'm not
gonna i'm just guessing but it's
but you notice that she looks like
thomas murphy
don't do that to our boy mm-hmm yes but
you know what's that it's always just
like you know it's like into free even
to do that
and to make it like you know i i don't
know why you
would make that into some kind of cruel
joke it's like that's not funny to me
it's this always on the ver this i
like even if you were saying nice things
in that voice i would be like
you need to shut the [ __ ] up i can't
hear that voice anymore
and yes somebody's pointing out why is
this other chick wearing a mask
i don't know man virtue's signaling ass
cause she's quirky it's all [ __ ]
everything's a fashion statement i'm
tired of all you
then for us to be the minority in a game
and i think my biggest issue isn't that
activision fired him right
because that's stupid and it's dumb but
you know what activision's gonna do
these dumb things right
it's the fact that these other people
that are supposed to be fellow gamers
right are sitting there ratting people
out like that probably that bob
that actually bothers me like 50 times
more than what activision did right but
are these fellow gamers or these just a
couple of
chicks that are have always been picks
they were chicks before they were on
twitch they were chicks when they were
in school
they're just miserable girls that's all
it is they're just
what do you do about that we could go
like it's not like it's
it's not like doctor disrespect and
[ __ ]
you know a bunch of prominent guys got
together and they were like wow
jeff leach's behavior is very
problematic and i think that they did
the right thing
they're not fellow gamers these are just
women that are angry about everything
and you could put them in any community
and they're going to be going wow is
everything going on to me so problematic
i'm hungry
that's all they're going to say gaming
community it just adds to everything
that is being said does that mean by
affiliation that facebook is okay with
what's being said i don't know
unfortunately look at this do you see
what i mean
the problem isn't even what these gaming
companies do or
the problem is these people you're led
into a club
and you have dudes simping to let you
into this club
and then when you're that's why the top
streamers are always gonna be dudes
that's by the way as much as i hate them
that's why somebody like a ninja is
always gonna be higher than you
that's why dudes doctor disrespect like
you mentioned
that's why these people always going to
be better than you because they're not
going to sit here and [ __ ]
cry because of [ __ ] something a
voice-over actor did
yeah i mean if if you if you look at the
top
20 biggest streamers right um
i don't think there's any women on that
list so it's like all you guys
especially you guys out there
um who [ __ ] who piss and moan about um
about like oh well these thoughts like i
always see that i see a lot of guys that
don't really do good streams they're
like he's [ __ ] it's hard for us when
we're doing streams these [ __ ]
thoughts get away with everything and
they
all they got to do is show their tits
and they can be better than us and it's
like
you're a man you fundamentally have an
advantage over them
you just happen to suck at streaming you
just happen to not be funny
you know what i mean so it's like
imagine if you're the female version of
that where you're also not funny and
also a female and you don't have nice
tits
and all that kind of [ __ ] like so but
royce is right most of the good
streamers
all the top ones making the most money
are men because they're funny
and because they're having fun and
because they're enjoying whatever
they're doing
and even if they're not funny men
men enjoy a hobby
or an activity in in in such a pure way
compared to women right it's like that
uh that meme about like
when when you take a picture of an
object and it's like men
it's like them just holding the camera
and the object in front of them and then
it's like women and it's like their face
in front of the object
um like guys can there's a reason why
there's so many like
gun uh channels and there's so many like
um
just these little hobby channels that
blow up and it's because a guy
just started filming himself doing some
weird [ __ ] he enjoyed
and excitedly going dude let me tell you
all about the sig sauer p320 you could
do this and we're going to do this and
later on we're going to put some
tannerite in a
washing machine and blow that up and
it's going to be so much fun
and and they're not sitting around going
hey guys
uh let's talk about some more of the
more problematic people in our community
and what we can do to remove them
like the best channels of the guy uh uh
steve mre guy
yeah yeah everyone loved he is
steve mre info guy in 1989 is
universally beloved by everybody that
watches him
because he doesn't he's not we don't
know what his politics is
we don't give a [ __ ] we don't know who
he voted for he never used the word
toxic or problematic he literally eats
hundred-year-old peanut butter
and smokes 80 year old camel cigarettes
and you go
this guy rolls okay this guy's got
that's why men do better at this stuff
fortunately perception is reality and
because it's
perception's not reality being allowed
to continue
review brah another one and another
iconic guy
because he's not sitting around going
you know i was sitting here yesterday
contemplating
uh as to whether or not the toxicity
on youtube and the internet has been
increasing
and who can we make a list of and have
them removed from society
like he doesn't he all he wants to do is
tell you how the brand new spicy chicken
sandwich and [ __ ]
[ __ ] popeyes is he just wants to do
his
stupid shortwave radio show and dress
like uh let's be fair dress like a
guy from louisville kentucky which is
fine
the perception then is that facebook or
activision is okay with
with those things being said standing
together is gonna do that for us
female gamers out there you have to take
a stand
congratulations taking a stand you
[ __ ] suck and not only now i'm gonna
make fun of you more
and you keep making stands
it's like you know that meme where the
angel of death keeps going from door to
door
that's what you women keep doing you've
you've
there isn't a club you've been led into
that you have not ruined
and you just keep you're like you are
like
[ __ ] parasites you are like
termites women are like locusts
they will just move from crop field to
crop fields
until there is no [ __ ] crops left
so this is the zombie unicorn person
this is the person he was making fun of
so i've been a little hesitant to
address this situation because
this kind of stuff really affects me
you're a little long in the tooth to be
doing this sweetheart am i wrong here
well not only that but she is another
twitch streamer who has followers
because she has her cleavage out when
she plays that's just a fact
but it's old cleavage look at this broad
by the way nice [ __ ]
uh eyebrow lying through your eyebrow i
like that that's the new look
she's a little old for this now
really like negatively and i'm not a
perfect person in the past i've
reacted poorly to witnessing or
experiencing
prejudice and hate and just
yeah i know attractive white women have
it you know i've always said there's
nothing
uh it's so unfortunate you know when you
were like 25 and you were better looking
i'm sure you had it
so rough i'm sure it was so i love when
women that look like this
are like i really really experienced uh
uh
oppression and it feels like we take one
step forward two steps back
and it's frustrating to see companies
posting
supporting women for women's history
month supporting black lives matter
putting a rainbow avatar
on their profile for pride month
and then allowing people to have free
speech in their private time no you're
right that's terrible by the way jim
jim just said lol attractive listen jim
i don't know what 1980s coca-cola
commercial you're [ __ ] living in
you know what i mean like i don't know
what i don't know what [ __ ] 1986
ferrari testarossa
anheuser-busch [ __ ] commercial
fantasy you're living in
but yeah she's i'm she's not she's older
and she's not she needs to
she needs to figure out a plan let's
just put it that way but to say she's on
a trip like she's not a pig i mean we
watch enough
we've seen enough test holidays and see
what happened to the [ __ ] world and
what what's what scraps are left for us
guys
she's not that bad but she somebody just
point out here she's she's 34.
sweetheart tick-tock i'm not trying to
be
and i'm not talking about the app like i
mean you got to come up with a plan
because being a victim of jeff leach
isn't going to work for you when you're
40 and you start getting those crow's
feet
and you start getting those [ __ ]
veins going through your tits
it's not gonna work big scrum says she's
never gonna make it on a big johnson
shirt merch
big johnson reference
[Laughter]
he was really horrible and and i had
enough
of it and i spoke out because
i i missed an opportunity to get paid
doing a show that i was gonna
have fun doing because i heard that he
was gonna be there
and i was like i'm sorry and you know
instead of like being like everybody
else who confronts
people and it would have been a good
show and it would have made me look
better and maybe even whatever
instead of you know calling him out i
was like i'm gonna run away from it
by the way all you guys in the chat room
saying that you wouldn't [ __ ] this on a
bad night stop it
stop lying okay she's not a knockout but
a couple drinks in if you're at a bar
you'd you'd [ __ ] that at night you know
some of you guys that are trying to
every time we bring up any woman they go
oh please it's below my standard most of
you guys hadn't had you dick sucked in a
year
before the pandemic hit so let's hop all
[ __ ] running around like
these chads that are that you're just
knocking [ __ ] flicking them off you
like [ __ ] hulk